[Music]
in
esports it can sometimes feel as if the
games we play
are scripted that players are shackled
by monolithic
metas and unspoken rules that force them
to fall into line
giving up self-expression in exchange
for likelier silverware
sk telecom have overcome every challenge
they are the undisputed best team in the
world
and while most players bow their heads
to these conventions and accept them as
blueprints to success
over the years we've been fortunate
enough to see
mavericks emerge who have rejected these
formulas
in favor of coming up with their own
trailblazers who
challenge their contemporaries to
rethink everything they
thought they knew about their games be
careful of one more he could handle here
dance we have
a animal of a champion here
and in league of legends you'll have a
hard time finding a more
off the wall experimenter than lay
sofm quang doi the hyper aggressive
vietnamese jungler of world's 2020
darlings
sooning a player whose mechanical
brilliance is surpassed
only by his ability to redefine and
reinvent
how the game is played that's always
interesting to me watching sfm
in the draft phase because looking at
that draft was like jarvan is a champion
yeah damn right javon is a champion
enemy team was immobile and
i don't know why but it's working and
it's hard to you know go against the
grain when it comes to sfm
a death-defying juggernaut who doesn't
march to the beat of anyone else's drum
he prefers to steamroll the opposition
to the beat of his own
they tried but now they've got juan fun
coming in from the side a very nice
bullet time
at the very end of the sleep angels in a
bad spot
but they may just turn it around good
golly miss molly everybody on jdg is
seeing black and white
so how is it that one of the most feared
and revered
junglers in league was able to emerge
from a minor region
and become one of the game's most
innovative stars
and how exactly did he help an
inexperienced chinese dark horse
reach the world's finals without
sacrificing his individual identity
along the way
he is just like perfect he is such an
incredibly
talented jungler and we say this all the
time but it's the world final so i'll
say it again
it's about time that sofm has finally
made it to the world stage
hey guys it's dimitri here now advancing
to the world's finals and surprising
everybody is not easy but you know what
is switching to geico
15 minutes could save you 15 or more on
car insurance
be sure to check out the link in the
description below now let's get back to
the video
despite being classified as a minor
region vietnam
has some of league of legends's most
passionate fans and a
wellspring of talent that has made its
presence felt on the world stage
nexus 2 is down the gigabyte marines are
looking for revenge
wild turtle gets the kill to archie look
at the nexus
take down tsm in fact i hate to say it
but there have been more vietnamese
players in grand finals at worlds than
north american ones
and by i hate to say it i mean i love to
say it
good morning vietnam
and the reason vietnam holds this claim
to fame is
sofm the bad boy jungler who understands
the rules of league
but prefers to break them sofm steps
back into the bush
jumps onto nagari jumps onto barrel does
it again a multi-man stun
once again from angel barrel will be
able to find the death centers and that
almost shots
down angel but there won't be enough
from the moonlight vigil but to
truly appreciate sofm flexing his
tank rengar in the finals of worlds
we need to go back a bit and understand
how he got there in the first place
you see sofm's journey began in 2013
when he was signed by full luis a team
competing in vietnam
although age restrictions hampered his
ability to play regularly
sofm's career really began to pick up
momentum once he turned 17.
and even at that tender age he was
already
turning heads sofm was a versatile
player capable of playing
mid or in the bot lane but it was in the
jungle that he began
forging his reputation
foreign
seeking a greater challenge sofm decided
to join the korean servers
and he didn't just survive with the
sharks he
thrived amongst them he became the first
ever vietnamese player to reach
top 10 challenger in korea and he did so
despite being at a significant ping
disadvantage
while playing mechanically demanding
junglers like lee sin
of course dumpstering competition like
that is definitely gonna get you noticed
and it wasn't long before sofm found
himself being recruited
by snake esports now china was no
stranger to importing players
but up to this point they'd mostly been
korean
so when he joined snake in summer 2016
sofm was the first ever vietnamese
player to break into the lpl
and unlike korea's ex-pats playing there
he was
hell-bent on playing the game his way
which makes a lot of sense
seeing as sofm literally stands for
style of me and that signature style
was based on pure aggression lots of
creep waves bashing on towards that
turret sofm now looking for a gang of
the snoopy gets him down low
should be on a flash for this one does
do just that he picks up first blood
flashed out of the way off there is the
never move does fly down the ultimate
comes out a 957 tank
is going to go down very very low but
she is going to be the first one to fall
first blood
goes to the lee sin is condi now off on
the wrong side
zero makes his way in as connie gets
kicked over and killed the double kill
comes in for sofm
tank was out of vision there's the
captive audience the ultimate flies
through
five in trouble and gets launched back
into snake
sofm's gonna easily be able to grab that
kill in a region known for its
bloodthirsty players
sofm took things to a whole other level
and his approach only made snake a
better team
but even with the few years in the
game's competitive scene under his belt
there was still a certain rawness to his
play that drew criticism
and while that solo q honed roughness
was
part of his charm every now and again it
did get him into trouble
controversies aside during his time with
snake
sofm established himself as a top tier
lpl player he was even named rookie of
the year in 2016
and mvp during the regional gauntlet in
spite of snake failing to qualify for
worlds
the turrets going down tnw have done it
in the fifth game against snake they're
able to take down snake esports and they
will advance into tomorrow's match
against i may the fight
anyway despite having the hot rookie
snake was never able to replicate the
success they enjoyed in 2016
but that didn't stop sofm's reputation
as a fearsome
jungler from growing especially a year
later when he began experimenting with
builds
using knight's vow now this tank item
didn't increase his
own damage but it made sofm nearly
impossible to kill
while harassing enemy backlines now
during the ardent sensor meta it made
sense to build this on gragas or sejuani
but sofm was choosing to play it on lee
sin
jarvan and even elise one of the things
that to me
um allows it to work for him is that you
know he's not just changing his
item build and trying to play the same
way he's changing his item build and
then trying to adapt his play style to
it you know allowing himself to like be
a lot more tanky in fights and kind of
be more of a nuisance like
you know go further into the back line
and try to get them to focus more damage
on him before being able to escape
because of his initial tankiness and
things like this and
i think it also works in his favor that
he's playing some of these champions
that
so many people play and and these
players have like almost a set in stone
expectation of what the champion can and
cannot do
because everyone always builds it and
plays it a similar way
and he is so far from that that i think
it kind of subverts expectation and it
makes it somewhat harder for his
opponents to really react to because
there's not really anyone else playing
this way so you
can't really practice against it sofm's
revolutionary mind for the game led to
another innovation in 2019
when he began to monopolize vision on
the map
through a creative game mechanic
by swapping between the sweeper and
warding totem trinkets
he was able to maximize his placed wards
while denying
vision to the opponent thanks to the way
their cooldowns worked
even after this specific mechanic was
patched out in december 2019
sofm remained a master of vision control
outpacing many of his peers and it was
this experimental and
off-the-wall approach to this game that
really made sofm
stand out among junglers i think sofm is
still one of the best junglers at that
he
always comes out with experience leads
and he really breaks a lot of the things
that we consider pillars as junglers
like take your buff on spot he's like no
no no no no you're just gonna walk
around
we don't need that after a brief stint
with lng in 2019
sofm joined sooning before the 2020
season began
there he found himself alongside sword
art angel
bin and juan feng it was a relatively
inexperienced lineup that
on paper had a lot of potential although
things didn't look that way in the
beginning
been with the defense duty as layan
jumps in
and that'll be all she wrote from ig and
sooning flashing on to the
fountain they're over the moon smlz
survives the fountain after all of that
2-0 over sunning
for next time the nexus is gonna go down
naturals here and dmo
taking after an 11th place finish in
spring
it looked as though soonings experiment
was going to result
in a massive flop but in the summer
things were very different sooning
responded to their initial
disappointment by putting together a
fourth place finish in the regular split
and an impressive run through the
regional finals
one that saw them triumph against lgd
gaming
for the first time ever sooning punched
their ticket
to the world championship but of course
that's not where sofm and sooning's
journey ended they weren't just grateful
to qualify for
worlds they were fully intent on winning
it back out they're not put together
you've got gameplay for the flight
gameplay
one big shot can you do it oh
my god one moment one shot one barrel
that's all you need
suiting with uh you know all of the
additional movespeed too
oh one more
arrow in his back to take kenavi down
ben trying to chase this up but where is
that chin
behind the curtains with the curtain
call everybody is done man juan fung is
legendary
they pick up the last two kills sooning
had ripped their way through every
pre-tournament favorite
putting together one of the most
difficult runs to grand finals in league
history and the only thing standing
between them and the summoner's cup
was korea's damn one gaming now any
reasonable person would probably think
that during the biggest series of his
life with
so much on the line sofm would probably
play it safe
but come on this is sofm we're talking
about
after a game one loss where he
unselfishly played
shen to allow for a counter pick he did
something crazy during the game 2 draft
his opposing jungler canyon locked in
evelyn now you've got canyon who is
considered
the best jungler in the world right now
and he's going to be playing this
champion
the ability to carry on it is uh like
extremely high
now instead of defaulting to something
expected like his signature lee sin
he threw caution to the wind he drew
deep on his wealth of solo queue
experience
and surprised everyone with his next
pick
let's go
and of course sofm rengar wouldn't be
sofm rengar without an
outrageous off meta tank build featuring
knight's foul i'm really curious as to
how soon are you going to play out these
fights i think they need to look for a
pick just like this
that's a root scat of the week unleashed
power excellent esther with him at
thrill of the hunt and he was waiting
juan fung reloads one two throws out the
grenade five shot number two the
dragon's going low
it's picked up by sunning they get
themselves the soul paddock in the fight
that's a flash forward one fight gets
canyon now noguri's left inside the pit
barrel's got no damage sofia steps back
into the bush
jumps onto longer he jumps onto barrel
does it again a multi-man stun
once again from angel barrel will be
able to find the death centers and that
almost shuts
down angel but there won't be enough
from the moonlight vigil and here comes
sofm looking
for barrel soon and get the soul sooning
step up and with rengar in game two
even out the series now unfortunately
for sofm and
suning their heroics in game 2 weren't
enough to stop
damwan from closing out the series with
wins in games 3
and 4. but despite falling short of
league's greatest prize
sooning's impressive run through worlds
remained incredibly important to sofm
not just because he'd finally been able
to prove himself as one of the world's
best junglers on the game's biggest
stage
but because of the covet 19 travel
restrictions imposed on vietnam
he'd been the lone representative for
his entire nation
i think it's it's a big deal right you
know having having a vietnamese player
you know in the finals
so i think you know that gave them you
know something to really cheer for and
you know i know like speaking from my
perspective if there was a canadian
player in the finals i'd definitely be
cheering for them i think that's
exciting to see
you know your your nation and your
league somewhat represented even if it
is
you know playing for a team from a
different country or a team um that's in
another league
and while i'm sure sofm would have loved
to be crowned a champion during his
first ever world's appearance
at the end of the day falling short
doesn't stop his
and soonings run from being every bit as
inspiring as it was
through his oddball ingenuity sofm was
able to help an
unproven and overlooked team of chinese
talent
become a serious international
contenders and
most importantly he did it by playing
the game
his way there is a reason that he has
style in his name as he is styling all
over damn one with this rengar
pick everything is wrong with league
what's right about league nothing
i don't hate anything in esports i love
esports like i love everything about
esports except for league of legends i
[ __ ] hate league of legends
oh sorry i get pukey when i have to do
league of legends it just makes me a
little